guys I've sat here in front of this
camera countless times to tell you about
groups of players who claim they've been
lied to who say they've been stolen from
who alleged that they've been taken
advantage of by someone looking to make
a quick buck in eSports but today is a
little different today I want to tell
you about a group of players who say
they were in as bad a situation as you
can imagine who lawyered up handled
their business and got a legal
resolution
[Music]
alright guys before we get on with the
rest of the video I want to say if you
haven't subscribed to the score eSports
yet what are you waiting for by
subscribing to the channel on this video
you let us know that you want more
investigative reports like this one so
go ahead and click that bell now let me
ask you this what would you do if you
were an eSports player and you thought
your org was withholding prize money and
salary if you thought they were lying to
you even defrauding you if when you
tried to confront the owner he
apparently withdrew every cent from
company bank accounts it deactivated his
email and disappeared well a group of
former players for eSports team know
Ventech alleged that's exactly what
happened to them and their answer was to
sue the owner of the org in August of
2018 five of them filed a legal
complaint against the owner and the org
suing him for fifty five thousand
dollars in unpaid prize money and salary
plus damages by January of this year the
case was settled out of court and the
players were reading an apology from the
former owner a guy called Jimmy Ross
Elliott at the second I've talked to
some of the players I've talked to their
lawyer and I've read all the legal
documents and I've never quite covered a
story like this one it all starts in
2016 when Zuna big impact B kid tomp
ster and Ken ma signed with the vent
--ax heroes of the storm roster you
remember heroes of the storm right
blizzards MOBA
shout out to all my Johanna mains now
according to the lawsuit these guys
signed contracts that guaranteed that
one thousand two hundred and fifty
dollars a month in salary plus most of
the prize money they earned as with most
of the eSports contracts that I've seen
these ones stipulate that the money goes
to the org first and then the org
distributes it amongst the players
within no more than ten days of
receiving it Dreamhack summer 2016 rolls
around and in June the team placed fifth
six at the heroes of the storm
tournament and net themselves
thirty-seven thousand five hundred
dollars in prize money it's six months
later in December when Dreamhack pays
out noventa the prize money the players
earned the problem the players say they
never got it the owner the guy I
mentioned earlier Jimmy Elliot
apparently told the players that it was
Dreamhack that never paid out in event
ik and therefore there was no prize
money to distribute totally continued on
and kept playing competing in phase 1 of
the 2017 heroes of the storm global
championship but in April of 2017
according to the lawsuit the players
find out that Dreamhack definitely did
pay out that money I believe we were at
like yeah I forget what it's called but
like at the beginning of the season
usually like they fly out all the people
and they do like media training stuff
and we were there since we're at
Blizzard headquarters or whatever the
those are two are they're just like you
know our team has apparently never been
paid and everyone else was there like
the Europeans genes are there and
they're like we've all been played so I
was like something's wrong for sure so I
was like who do I got to talk to to
actually figure this out and they're
like you know we'll definitely get to it
and then that's when we finally figured
out that like we've been paid the
players confront Elliot and he allegedly
tells them he'll pay them back the prize
money plus some back salary that he owes
them at this point he not only owes the
players the dreamhack money but
apparently tens of thousands of dollars
in unpaid salary as well it's at this
point that Elliot allegedly breaks out a
set of excuses that I've encountered in
pretty much every single one of these
cases we're talking Bank errors money
transfer issues
pal fuck-ups a set of miraculous reasons
why eSports teams claim they can't pay
their players the money they're owed you
want some more deja vu well stop me if
you've heard this one before according
to the lawsuit Elliott allegedly
withdraws all of the money from the new
vendek corporate bank accounts and
disappears according to the players he
ceases all communications he won't
answer Twitter DM Skype calls
he's deactivated his email address he's
completely ghosted incredibly at this
point the players and the staff at
noventa stick together and they keep
grinding despite the [ __ ] storm that's
raging around them but eventually in
August of 2017 well over a year after
playing in the Dreamhack summer event
the players terminate their contracts
and leave the org one year later after
having to hire a private detective to
track down the former owner of the org
and after 14 attempts to serve him with
the legal papers the five former members
of the team file their lawsuit I know
what they did is illegal but I don't
know like how it's gonna be like
Punisher like how we're gonna get repaid
and stuff like that so like yeah I just
know it's like all I can do is go to a
lawyer and that gets on me my hostages
and stuff like that and my best chances
of winning and stuff and like I know I
just it's completely out of my field so
like you know talking to the lawyers and
like learning like what they can do and
like all this stuff and like more than
anything I just want to know what
happened to it and like how if someone
could steal all that money just be like
totally fine be like rip you know just
in that sense we didn't just dive into
the lawsuit itself there were you know
in the interim demand letter sent and
also even you know private investigators
that had to be hired to locate ownership
you know unfortunately as with many
sports organizations there were many
individuals that claimed to be owners
that seemed like they weren't Oh
actually owners or couldn't produce any
sort of human tation that they were
owners so there was a lot of legwork
that that we had to do and he tried to
resolve this of course without ever even
pursuing litigation and Alessa just
didn't shake out that way so
we have escalate and according to that
lawsuit the former owners business
practices were very problematic from the
get-go for starters the lawsuit alleges
that Jimmy Elliot that's the former
owner remember lied to the state of
Arkansas about who was actually in
control of noventa k-- it also alleges
that he failed to maintain proper
banking and accounting records and that
because of that noventa k-- was quote
grossly undercapitalized to meet its
obligations and quote it also alleges
that he used noventa company money for
personal expenses that he failed to pay
the proper business taxes in the state
of Arkansas and that the state
consequently revoked his limited
liability corporation status now for
Jimmy Elliot's part in January of 2019
he does issue a formal response to the
legal complaint but there's not much to
it suffice to say it is the usual legal
equivalent of know you one year after
that in January of 2020 right before
this case is scheduled to go to court
the former owner Jimmy Elliot and the
five players reach a settlement now
because of the way these things work the
details of the settlement are private
neither the lawyer nor the players nor
Elliot are legally allowed to divulge
who got what and how but we do know one
thing as part of the settlement Elliot
had to issue a public apology and it
reads as follows my involvement with
noventa LLC both as a member and as
unpaid CEO was challenging regardless of
my efforts to assist noventa LLC become
a successful eSports organization
desired results were not obtained such
resulted in a negative impact on
people's lives including zouna Kenema B
kid big impact and Tom ster I am truly
sorry that has to be one of the most
half-assed apologies I have ever read I
am sure Elliot did his legal minimum
requirement when writing that still it's
got to feel good for the players and
they say they're happy with the outcome
of the case because it can stand as an
example to other eSports professionals
who might be in similar situations now
if you're wondering where Blizzard
wasn't all of this the publisher of
heroes of the storm and the organizer of
the 2017
heroes of the storm global championship
which an event a participated in was
apparently pretty much just completely
hands-off as far as Blizzard was
concerned
apparently in regards to this situation
it was too bad better luck next time
still zouna does note that Blizzard
changed some of its rules surrounding or
participation after the noventa incident
um it wasn't too much of a conversation
it was literally like just a shutdown
like they couldn't they just told us
like oh we can't help you and like it's
a shitty situation but like was it like
at that point it was like a but it
wasn't like a full like Blizzard League
but after we got [ __ ] over they did
change it a lot like for the next clip
they had like you had to have like a LLC
and it had to be like some one part of
the team so they had like 100 thunders
of contact and they had it so like they
made sure after we got [ __ ] over that
you couldn't pretty much be [ __ ] over
anymore but like before that they really
were just like you know we can't really
help you they didn't give us a lawyer or
anything you know they were just like
well that sucks but that's just like the
wrist you know and then next but they
are one I made it like like the next
like thing they were like changing and
so that people didn't get screwed over
and you lose easy and stuff like that
but for sure yeah definitely sucks
especially at the time there's like you
you think like like a like multi
billionaire company would be like oh if
someone trying to screw him over we got
their backs but at the time just it was
what it was and it's just like like I
said we were definitely naive to think
that it the way it is and like all these
big companies and all the stuff is like
unless you're the star of their show
they really don't care about you at all
like you can even be the best player in
any game and like if you can't buy
anymore and you're not like you know
you're not gonna be any part of their
business they don't care they'll drop
you instantly so like it's just just a
learning experience more than anything
so what if you're watching this right
now
and you're the one in the messed up
situation you are the one not getting
paid
getting gaslighted and ghosted by owners
well i asked the players lawyer roger
Quiles what advice he has in short guys
talk to a lawyer know your options but
really just echo the whole you know talk
to a lawyer about your situation as
realistically and especially a lawyer
that's hillier with the space and how
the business side of it works
because then they can help you fully
assess your options or give you sort of
the perspec anding your perspective and
also saying alright well but this is
what your contract says this is
perspective you know this is what
reality would look like if we were to
try to pursue this you know these are
all your alternatives you know it
doesn't have to be a whole blow-up with
your org about you know hey where's my
money
hey what's going on you know generally
they tend to be more strategic ways of
you know having those conversations in
an amicable way and then at that point
you know it's saying alright well what
are my legal rights and how can I
exercise those I know some of you guys
look at what's on the back of my shelf
and point things out like how the Game
of Thrones books were in the wrong airs
but I don't know if any of you have
looked in this corner before because I
am a big Godzilla fan we have just a few
juicy Godzilla pieces right here we've
got Godzilla vs. space Godzilla it was
basically fat Godzilla with crystals
coming out of him Godzilla and Mothra
battle for Earth Godzilla versus
destoroyah Godzilla
spoiler alert dies in this one
quote-unquote dies this one's wild
Godzilla versus King Ghidorah classic
probably the most beloved Godzilla
villain love the art on these old these
old VHS tapes man